den abend wir waren richtig müde
ich glaube meine nintendo auf die
falsche seite kaputt war und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video alter
ich bin heute richtig energiegeladen
aber das kann selbstständig nur daran
liegen dass der markt mit dabei
guten tag die herren und die herren und
bewundert hunde ich bin ein bisschen
krank leute gehört wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen schnupfen aber das hält uns
nicht davon ab heute wieder eine folge
zuschauer story reactions zu machen und
wir legen direkt los und bis auf diese
studie ist richtig gestört das ist
wirklich so wo hat daher in der
grundschule machten wir meistens einen
kreis um dann zu besprechen was alles
gut oder schlecht ist
also saß nicht in meine klasse kollegen
dort und ja auf einmal musste ich
richtig hart geht es los und alles mal
leise dann sagt der lehrer
jetzt aber dringend aufs klo geht noch
in die hose xd dass ich gegen ihn vor
die tür und lassen noch lassen noch
einen kurz und fing wieder ihm die
klasse punkt xd alles klar leute
straight aus dem baby universum und wird
wieder fleißig geputzt wir machen einen
kreis um dann zu besprechen was alles
gut oder schlecht ist
wer kennt denn wer kennt noch aus der
grundschule leute was glaubst du wurde
schlechte versprochen seine
rechtsprechung
ich weiß nicht es wurde besprochen ob
die gut oder schlecht das war sicher
auch ein thema dieser runde großer
philosophen leute was ist das für ein
szenario sind in der grundschule welcher
mensch setzt sich in der grundschule
zusammen mit freunden und diskutiert das
deutsche volk hat das interesse an der
demokratie verloren nein ich glaube dass
die klassenkonferenz und das heißt wenn
jemand ärger miteinander hatten 28 krass
ich habe ja irgendwie immer die ganzen
alten schulhof gedacht aber das steht
echt nix dem schulhof der teil von das
deutlich auf jeden fall glaubt insgesamt
glaube ich das eigentlich so ja ja
leider dass der lehrer xd gesagt hat
doch hat er gesagt ich kenne ja leute
wenn euer grundschullehrer schon einiges
gesagt hat dann lässt man neigte next
story leute das ist eine geschichte zu
der max nicht auch sehr in sehr starken
persönlichen bezug haben und zwar halte
ich fest mal als ich noch klein war also
vor ungefähr zehn jahren gehe ich meiner
mutter zum einkaufen und als wir an der
kasse standen stand dort ein punker und
ich sagte zu meiner mutter das fast
schon lange vorbei er wollte einfach
alles mit
das habe ich einfach mit drei genommen
weil es ist doch fasching ist der der
all time classics brust um dinge zu
erklären leute als jetzt wieder nicht
gesehen aber wir das schon mal gesagt
haben fasching ist eigentlich die
erklärung für halle in überschrift
fasching war es ja ihr seid besonderes
auto gefahren hat unfall gebaut und sagt
ihm officer es war fasching oder ihr hab
gedacht so fasching oder aber ihr habt
allahu akbar gerufen
sagten polizisten einfach ist fasching
bruder ja
alter stellt ja vorher sagt dass
fasching ist wir müssen alles
zurücknehmen da alle tweets löschen
alle rainbow flex die holsteinische
gepostet wurden wieder zurück alter
alles klar nächste geschichte ich habe
abends heimlich youtube in meinem bett
geguckt youtube geguckt you tube
gedrückt in anführungszeichen dann kam
meine mutter rein sollte so tun als ob
ich musik hören würde und versteckte
mein handy unter der bettdecke summte
dazu weil wir nichts anderes eingefallen
ist
leise rieselt der schnee und bewegt
meine hände dazu im takt und yahoo ich
kann es nicht mache man sich eben heute
vor den rücken vergleichbare übung aber
ich mache euch nur verachtung hoch
kennst du das auch also ich weiß nämlich
aber jeglichen youtube gestellt wofür
steht youtube schauen abends im bett
heimlich youtube geschaut ob wir könnte
stehen ja ich musste mir vorstellen was
ein kleines kind du weißt es richtiger
youtube sucht die richtig gestört
deswegen laufen abends rein und du weißt
du weißt dass dieser sohn oder die
tochter wie der youtube schaut und das
ist einfach ein riesen und bewegt seine
warte ich will dass du dieses diese
vision vor deinen augen hast op stell
dir vor du gehst ins zimmer rein und
dann einfach weiß was wir machen jetzt
zusammen denn ganz okay bewegt deine
hände im takt
[Musik]
hmm
der nächste story aufschlag alles klar
ich hatte mal eine nintendo habe mit
freund zog den abend wie ihre waren
richtige mittel
ich glaube meine nintendo auf die
falsche seite kaputt von java zu den
fakten bildschirm abreisen
[Musik]
zerfetzte sein ding als ob das passiert
alle die noch bei ihren eltern wohnen
kennen den hassel wenn man einfach
zocken muss und sein handy aber sein
game boy irgendwo verstecken muss junge
ich habe auch schon gehasst unsere
mutter hat mir früher und das stromkabel
zum computer weggenommen weil die
tastatur da ich mir so viel tastaturen
und stromkabel neu gekauften ist
unwahrscheinlich heute das ist auch
wichtig crash achtlos hey sebastian marx
erstmal probst an eure videos nicht
vollständig weiß an deine videos okay
okay okay war nicht so witzig alles klar
zu meiner story als in der siebten oder
achten klassen war bin ich mit meinen
zwei freunden im treppenhaus der schule
mal hinter unserer biologie lehrerin
hergelaufen die hat der eine zu enge
jeans sagen ich dann natürlich mit dem
hintergedanken total lustig zu sein zu
meinen freundinnen u voll der knackig
allerdings war das würde nicht ganz so
leise wie ich dachte
der trip nach sagt drehte lehrern sie
schmunzelt um und meinte danke an junge
nur ordert sie haben wir alles zusammen
aber wisst ja ganz ehrlich leuten ich
glaube das passiert uns allen deutlich
öfter als wir denken dass wir einfach
irgendwas sagen und denken die anhören
es nicht aber sie uns volle kanne
ich glaube auch also wirklich das
passiert tausend mal ich hab schon so
viele sachen gesagt niemand hören sollen
weil ich einfach ich mache gerne witze
ja also ich sage keine ahnung also was
aber ich sage gerne so ein bisschen
provokante sachen zu meinen freunden in
der öffentlichkeit dann hören zeit
andere dann hast mich alle sehr schöne
zusammenfassung des videos leute alle
hassen es aber ihr müsst max nicht
hassen dann mag es in der beschreibung
verlinkt und ihr könnt ihr abonnieren
und lassen viele haben danach gefragt
deswegen gibt es das wieder und zwar
darum nach oben sagt du zeit bis zum
nächsten leute haut kein macht's gut und
[Musik]